bonsoir est ce que ces chars pays 44
milliards américains oui c'est cher payé
parce que lorsqu'on regarde la situation
depuis qu'ils ont de masques annoncé son
offre il ya pas une contre offre pour
créer une surenchère sur la société et
comme on vient de le mentionner la
société va avoir un lourd endettement
une des principales banques américaines
s'apprêtent à faire un prêt de 13
milliards pour cette acquisition la
société qui déficitaire donc ça va pour
les actionnaires actuellement je pense
que c'était une offre qui pouvait pas
refuser les actionnaires d'une bonne
transaction se faire offrir 54 dollars
20 l'action c'est la meilleure chose qui
pouvait leur arriver je pense que oui je
crois que le conseil du strass y ont agi
dans l'intérêt des actionnaires si on
garde toute heure et rentrer en bourse
en 2013 environ 45 dollars le prix de
l'action donc la société après un léger
gain pendant une période où la
croissance des réseaux sociaux était
vraiment vraiment croissance son frère
comparatif twitter ses revenus ont
augmenté de 12 pour sa part année puis 8
heures durant la même période facebook
puis on parle maintenant que facebook
ait atteint certaine maturité quand même
à augmenter ses revenus de 40 % durant
la même période à chaque année c'est
quand même très intéressant donc c'est
une entreprise qui a des problèmes de
croissance et qui perd de l'argent la
plupart du temps quand même on remonte
il ya deux ans il y avait elliott une
firme de gestion de portefeuille qui
avait fait de l'activisme afin
d'accélérer un nouveau modèle d'affaires
on a parlé de l'abonnement c'est un
projet qui était de démarrer mais malgré
toutes les discussions un changement de
président pdg qui ont eu récemment c'est
au pas vraiment traction pour vraiment
donner une croissance exponentielle mais
ce qu'ils ignorent ce que va donner
cette croissance mais c'est difficile
parce que jusqu'à présent on a on a un
partage de son opinion qui est
idéologique
mais comment ce modèle peut vraiment
donner une croissance dans get
actuellement comment on l'a vu la
société a des revenus de 5 milliards bon
si on veut augmenter les revenus on peut
vendre touchard la pub mais pour ça
probablement faudrait donner dé partager
des données sur les utilisateurs puis
maintenant on est complètement inverse
la maison blanche a renforcé son opinion
qu'on veut resserrer l'accès à
l'information le deuxième volet c'est de
vendre plus de publicité maintenant si
le contenu n'est plus et moins modérée
sur la plateforme tête les fai vont être
complètement et vers celui des grandes
sociétés vont même s'éloigner toiture et
une barre ce que disait qu'il voulait
changer le modèle publicitaire parce
qu'on voyait tantôt 217 millions
d'utilisateurs qui sont exposés à au
moins une publicité par jour
et toitures qui voulait augmenter ça si
je me trompe pas 315 millions l'an
prochain personne n'y croit vraiment
comme modèle d'affaires finalement oui
parce que ça ça va créer une friction au
niveau de l'utilisation du produit puis
jusqu'à présent pour elle il n'ya pas
clarifié clairement quel va être son
modèle d'affaires pour ramener
l'entreprise à un autre niveau il faut
se rappeler que tout récemment twitter a
mentionné que ce n'est pas l'argent qui
motive est derrière cette transaction la
wii qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
actionnaires de tesla par ce qui est des
actions tesla en garantie les actions de
dire une mosquée ce que ça peut avoir un
effet sur la valeur des actions tesla
éventuellement oui peut-être parce que
lorsqu on déballe le montage financier
que mes formations qu'on arrive à avoir
un prêtre 13 milliards un autre quart du
financement c'est de 13 milliards c'est
il en vaut mettre en garantie environ 60
68 milliards de valeur de ses actions le
tiers qui détient dans tesla et une
marge de crédit vont être utilisés donc
ça ça va permettre à acheter 50 pour sa
part un montage financier pour acheter
la moitié de twitter l'autre moitié ça
doit de les quitter la liquidité est ce
qu'il rende d'un an garantie d'autres
actifs est-ce qu'ils vont vendre des
actions de tesla à voir puis l'on se
projette dans le temps puis l'entreprise
quand même la misère à pivoter son
modèle d'affaires puis les bars qui
demande un appel de marge sur les
actions est en garantie sauf si ça peut
créer de la pression sur le prix d'été
cela surtout que tesla c'est un peu une
bête à part parce que depuis cet automne
on a vu vraiment une pression dans tout
les titres de croissance pourtant
l'action tesla a vraiment tenu la route
j'ai aujourd'hui sa valeur qui est
environ 2000 milliards et particuliers
même si la société tesla chuté de 50% ce
sera encore le plus gros fabricant en
bourse de véhicules automobiles donc
faut prendre ça en considération donc
donc il a dit löw delà il de la marge de
la possibilité lune masque peut s'amuser
s'il le veut effectivement puis cette
transaction droite historique parce que
des transactions de 44 milliards il y en
a eu dans le passé mais c'est par des
sociétés technologiques des conglomérats
mais ici on parle d'un individu qui lui
écrire un chèque de 44 milliards c'est
particulier mais qu'elle peut se
permettre ça c'est par la création de
richesses créées dans la dernière
décennie ce que c'est une icône type de
transaction - effectivement un individu
qui achètent une société de cette taille
là c'est ça va être la première fois et
pourquoi le conseil d'administration qui
sembler rébarbatif
cette transaction la changer d'idée je
pense qu'au début comme un élan de
masques communiquer le message récemment
pris au sérieux parce que la provocation
ce divin comme un veau pouvoir financer
une transaction si grande pour cette
société là dans un deuxième temps est
revenu avec des partenaires financiers
crédible qui a commencé à dévoiler son
montage financier donc c'était sérieux
si l'autre côté les administrateurs
trouve pas d'autres acquéreurs pour
créer potentiel pour faire une
surenchère je me demande comment il
aurait pu se présenter au conseil annuel
devant les autres actionnaires puis pour
dire pour dire qu'ils ont refusé un oeuf
de 54 $ comptant oui c'est difficile à
justifier donc un certain moment je
pense le conseil nostra sont acceptés
dans l'intérêt des actionnaires c'est
trop plein merci beaucoup simon plan
très intéressant merci bien merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit